yesterday was a sporting day yeah
and it continued into last night it's
continued into today
joining us now from u.s today sports
um bob nightingale to talk to us about
all this baseball movement and what it
means for your favorite team out there
bob welcome to the show
yeah thanks man um
first off let's start with my cubs okay
because uh
i bought all these jerseys five years
ago around the world series time
and now they're um obsolete
rizzo's gone chris bryant's numbers were
out there in terms of kyle schwarber is
now with the
boston red sox what what are the cubs
doing and it wasn't just long too long
ago where they were winning
a world series
yeah they wouldn't rebuild i mean they
uh they tried to lock up rizzo
and spring training often five years at
70 million
uh you know he turned it down you know
bryant they've offered
got like 200 million dollars a couple
years ago you turn that down
so i think they just said you know time
has come our window was shut
they haven't won a uh you know playoff
game since 2017
and that was the time so uh yeah
i i think they're gonna be you know down
for a few years now rebuilding that
thing
all right so let's talk to let's talk to
uh bob nightingale here from the usa
today sports a little bit about some of
those big moves all right the the one
out here in la everybody's talking about
max scherzer was the name floating
around with a bunch of different teams
the red sox
the padres looks like it's going to be
to the dodgers with trey turner
with that move how does that solidify
the dodgers chances at making another
run at a world series
oh great move uh i mean freddy turner is
unbelievable i know we all know about
shares his resume but turner's probably
the top 10 players in baseball
terrific shortstop complete different
positions too would prefer to stay at
shortstop
you know maybe they can move siegel to
second base you know we have turner has
his wishes
but a uh you know shirts are on top that
rotation
so we have rotation you know with the uh
you know
walker bueller uh scherzer and and
kershaw
very tough to beat so you know they're
all in uh
you know they get they have about 275
million dollar payroll so they should be
hauled in
right i think it's a baseball history
but a uh
you know just think i'm a gun right i
mean they lose uh
you know lose bauer you know probably
won't pitch you know one piece the rest
of the year
dustin may and uh you know kershaw's
been out with some nagging injuries too
yeah a big move for this uh dodgers team
trying to repeat
um we talked about the rizzo move a
little bit goes to the yankees
going to play first base for them added
bat
surprisingly enough for how poorly at
times this yankees team has played
they found a way to stay above 500 and
put themselves in a chance to make a run
at the playoffs
this edition of rizzo going to be a
difference maker
uh it you know gallo and rizzo i think
you know should give them a boost to get
a wildcard spot
i don't see them making up nine games on
the red sox uh
you know they're just they're not that
they're not that good
and they uh they still need some
pitching they're trying to get a starter
and
relief picture as we speak uh you know
there's still a lot of strikeouts in
that lineup
so we'll see what happens but it puts in
position at least
to get a wild card spot then you have
coal pushing a wild card game
so then you're you know back to square
one so you know
they're going for this thing and while
also staying below the uh electric jacks
kyle schwarber of cubs hero
cubs fans uh we watch him bounce around
and now he's
gonna end up in boston chris brockman
here loving that edition
where is he going to play what kind of
uh impact will he make for this boston
red sox team that's seemingly
starting to run away with the al east
when they're going to try to play him at
first base uh see what happens he hasn't
played first base
but you know nobody thought he could
play left field and he was fine in left
field
uh he was athletic enough but you know
he can play first base
clinton play left field obviously dh uh
you know he
will probably won't be healthy for a
couple more weeks um
you know but but then he'll be a uh it
could be
impactful player uh we saw what he did
in washington with that
10-day stretcher when he hit 12 home
runs so
he should help he should help them out
yeah definitely
it's fun to to see all these former cubs
go off to have
great careers everywhere else but uh it
is what it is uh
yeah bob this is chris here uh the aoes
now is just
looking like it's gonna be absolutely
bananas down the stretch with the blue
jays acquiring jose berrios
are you surprised that the blue jays are
making a run at this are you surprised
that the yankees were buyers here at the
deadline
well the you know the blue jays are
going back home for the first time in
270 days today
uh at the uh rogers center in toronto
and i think they wanted to make a splash
you'll get burials for uh one more year
after this
they trade away to the top prospects and
usually uh they haven't done that
uh this trade downline we're seeing
teams you know trade more prospects than
ever
you know yankees trade away uh with six
prospects now
uh in in having those teams pay the
money to keep them down below the luxury
tax
so it used to be that teams are trying
to protect the prospects a lot
but now i think people are saying you
know what prospects are cool but you
know pray
for cooler we're talking with bob
nightingale usa today
mlb uh columnist i think surprising a
lot of people the san francisco giants
have
made this nl west a very interesting
division
padres were in the mix for the max
scherzer sweepstakes uh
their bats have been extremely powerful
this year
and the dodgers went in a different
direction to try to solidify
them as the the dominant force where do
you see this
division shaking out and if there is one
weakness with the dodgers right now
it kind of continues to be maybe that
that closing bullpen
kenley janssen some of those things that
have happened in particular leighton
games
where do you think the dodgers have to
shore up everything to
to try to repeat uh this season
well yeah i'm with you they could use
another reliever and i think they'll get
another reliever i mean they've talked
to the cubs about craig kimbrough
you know like that tends to be too steep
of a price but maybe they say you know
what
we're all in we'll put that payroll at
you know 285 million dollars
and give up more prospects for kimberle
uh so they got the
inver prospect inventory to do so right
yeah i think they uh
you know kelly jensen was having an
all-star first half
uh you know he's scuffled here i just
don't
i think they need another arm to help
that out i mean they uh
you know joe kelly has been that you
know dependable when he's healthy
but otherwise it's been uh those guys
haven't produced
so i'm with you i think they got to get
more more reliever if they really want
to
shut this thing down all righty bob
nightingale everybody from usa today
talking to us all about the ongoings the
last few days
um we'll have you back soon probably
when
all these trades become final and uh
and we're rolling towards the end of the
season bob thanks for joining us
jeremiah thank you guys bob nightingale
everybody
usa today major league baseball
columnist hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here